first up he is a lifelong champion of
the environment who appears in the
documentary trace amounts available now
online is the editor of the Marisol let
the science speak a book on the same
issue Robert F Kennedy jr. is back ago
Robert seemed so long how are you you
look great
well ok so I saw you of a full-page ad
that you printed in USA Today about this
issue to Marisol which is the
preservative the mercury-based
preservative in vaccines we'll get to
that the second but I want to put it in
context you are one of the greatest
environmental Crusaders we've ever had
so I'm assuming and I think anyone would
just be a fad so your history with
mercury goes back a long way
I mean your interaction heading now but
you've gotten it out of rivers right I
got I got dragged into the vaccine as
you kind of kicking and screaming
because I was going around the country
suing coal burning power plants and
talking about the dangers of mercury
coming from those plans and almost
everywhere I stopped on or I spoke I
there were women there very eloquent
articulate grounded people who were
saying look you have to look at the
biggest vector of mercury in American
children now is coming from vaccines and
we need you to look at this science and
uh I resisted for a long time but I
started reading a science after a while
and I am very comfortable reading
science i i've brought hundreds and
hundreds of successful lawsuits almost
all of them have involve scientific
controversy to tell I look I'm good I'm
I'm comfortable reading science and
dissecting it and discerning the
difference between junk science and real
science and when I started looking at it
what I saw was very alarming which we
were giving huge amounts of mercury to
our children a lot of it has been taken
out of vaccines but there's a great
ordinary I'm still in the backs and
particularly the flu vaccine but what
you